[Music]
meet anna finance is her forte
but the work isn't always fun every week
she builds a report that includes
expenses from all the invoices across
our company's entire finance management
system
it's a lot
sometimes the invoices are pdfs created
from digital files but sometimes they're
just scanned paper invoices entering
them and creating the reports takes lots
of valuable time away from more crucial
work and the manual repetition means
errors could be right around the corner
thanks to ibm robotic process automation
with ai driven bots she now can automate
her reports and lots of other repetitive
tasks too
her first step is to activate ibm rpa
studio a place where she can easily
create automation scripts
[Music]
scripts contain the steps that tells the
bot what it needs to do rpa studio has a
host of simple to use tools to help
automate different types of tasks
anna easily builds her bot by dragging
and dropping commands from the studio's
toolbox onto the script design surface
rpa commands have instructions that
clarify what her bot will execute
anna adds a command for her bot to
specify the folder containing the pdfs
it needs to process
she then grabs the data she needs from
the pdf using optical character
recognition or ocr
anna can also use the recorder to add
commands to her script by recording them
in the finance management system
when recording starts ibm rpa
automatically adds commands to anna's
script based on the steps she takes in
her browser
when she is done recording anna can make
extra tweaks to her script if she needs
to
and done
after publishing the bot the script is
stored in the cloud and can be reused as
needed it also becomes a resource
available to other users
anna can start her bot whenever she
needs it and the bot takes care of the
rest
a task that would take anna hours even
days to complete is done in minutes
all she has to do is click a button
now while the bot takes care of the
repetitive functions anna can focus on
high value work you know the stuff that
puts the fun in finance
[Music]
you